okay I guess I should say although maybe
I don't need to that this segment is not
a politically correct segment if you've
been watching this program for a while
you know that political correctness has
never been really a priority of mine and
those that are in the so-called the
realist movements are going to know what
I mean
sometimes you've got to call things what
they are and sometimes you have to
realize that what you believe to be an
accurate representation of the world
simply isn't and what I'm talking about
is that there are all sorts of really
smart pieces all over the place about
what's happening to our country what's
happening in the United States right now
under Trump's America you have American
writers and foreign writers who are
trying to sort of figure out what
exactly has led to this trumpian America
status quo in which we find ourselves
during the year 2019 how can people be
so gullible some writers have ascribed
this to fear of losing status real or
perceived influenced people into voting
for Donald Trump in 2016 and yet that is
part of it
others have ascribed to racism and
xenophobia the motivation to vote for
someone like Donald Trump and of course
that's a part of it for sure I can't
deny that we've seen people like
Dilbert's creator scott adams say that
it's donald trump's skills at persuasion
and influence even if he doesn't get
every policy Trump's persuasion skills
influenced a lot of people to vote for
him and yeah okay that's part of it you
have the Hillary was a bad candidate
angle and yeah okay that was part of it
but that doesn't explain why Trump today
maintains an approval rating in the high
30s or low 40s depending on where and
when you look we've heard the meme of
tribalism and partisanship cited as why
we have so many people who support Trump
despite being an obvious liar in terms
of what he will do and not really even
understanding the policies that he
espoused
that's also part of it but we are not
going to get beyond
the situation in which we find ourselves
today until we admit that there are just
lots of dumb people and some of them
vote and they don't understand anything
and they're not going to understand
anything so that a solution to the
current problem is going to require it's
going to have to be a solution that
doesn't include them all right part of
its cultural that's just a reality part
of it is a class issue part of it is
because education and thinking itself
have been stigmatized and smeared as
liberal nonsense I'll give you some
examples
Trump's trade bloviating if you believe
a conman who knows nothing about trade
that he's going to fix the problem and
eliminate the trade deficit and then you
see the numbers that the trade deficit
is up despite all of his negotiations
and the tariffs and everything else at a
certain point a person who is informed
and capable of critical thinking says
you know what he lied and he's a con man
and I can't support him anymore
the tax cuts for middle America we were
told everybody's everybody's getting a
tax cut and now you have as I told you
last week Republicans furious on Twitter
about what they see is tax increases
some of them are actually tax increases
because they were duped others don't
understand that your refund doesn't
actually tell you what your total tax
liability was it's because they're just
not knowledgeable and we're not going to
be able to inform them we're gonna have
to find a solution that doesn't include
these people Trump building a wall with
Mexico that Mexico will pay for that was
never going to happen right there was
never going to be a wall built across
the us-mexico border that Mexico was
going to pay for and it's also clear
according to engineers as we looked at
in detail two weeks ago that there's not
going to be a wall built period across
the entire us-mexico border during
Donald Trump's presidency whether it
goes on two more years or six more years
the best-case scenario for a wall
builder is that Trump will get a few
billion for some tiny portion of it
period it would take a decade or more
even if we started now to do what Trump
wants to do and we don't even have the
money for
at this point so it's not happening but
you have trumpets who continue believing
it either because of cognitive
dissonance or as I'm increasingly
convinced simply ignorance believing in
the idea of tax cuts for the rich as
good for the country we saw that the tax
cuts for the rich under Reagan the tax
cuts for the rich under Trump didn't
work and raise the deficit and the exact
same thing is happening under Donald
Trump at a certain point you have to say
it's not just tribalism it's also
ignorant when you have a system that
makes it easier to get a gun than to
drive a car this is simply inconceivable
in most developed countries the world is
aghast at this but there's a bunch of
people who are just not smart enough to
realize how crazy it is and then on top
of this you have to drop the vicious
cycle of right-wing media like Fox News
people watch Fox News because they
believe that no one other than Fox News
is telling them the truth and then we
know that the more you watch Fox News
the less informed you are even compared
to watching no news at all and it
reinforces the idea that nobody tells
you the truth other than Fox News it's a
circle of idiocy
now let me preempt what I know some of
you are going to say about this story I
will get emails and tweets from people
saying David this is why Trump won your
liberal arrogance about trumpets being
dumb is why Trump won and will win again
no sorry
smart people aren't voting for Trump
because liberals say that they're dumb
on Twitter right that's not the issue
this is why arguing with trumpets to try
to win elections is a loser's game and
why I am insisting it's it's happening
every other show at this point that I am
reminding you if we want to win in 2020
it's going to happen
despite trumpets not because of them
because we've convinced them to change
their minds it's just not going to
happen
period and that's why get-out-the-vote
is the most important tactic to take
power back from this administration in
2020 tell me where I'm going wrong I
would love to hear from you
okay we should talk a little bit about
the health of the President of the
United States of America there have been
question marks around Donald Trump's
physical health for a long time and this
isn't Hillary has Parkinson's sort of
conspiracy stuff this is really a very
sort of sober and concerning issue if
you think back to the first strange
statement that we got from a medical
professional about Donald Trump's health
it was that letter from his doctor
Bornstein during the campaign which said
that Donald Trump was not only in great
health he would be the healthiest of any
president in the history of the United
States which is a really strange thing
for a medical professional to say
particularly when they've not examined
former presidents of the United States
so that was weird
to begin with as a general sort of
reality it's very clear that Donald
Trump is obviously not as healthy as
President Barack Obama we only have to
go back one president and there's really
no way in which an obese 72 year-old who
eats tons of fast food and never
exercises could be healthier then the
40-something person that Barack Obama
was when he became president of the
United States as an active and in shape
person so it didn't make sense from the
get-go and we eventually found out that
dr. Bornstein actually wrote that letter
under pressure from Donald Trump Donald
Trump according to some sources actually
dictating the letter and Bornstein
ultimately acquiescing and signing off
on it so that was sort of episode one in
the Trump health situation we later
heard from dr. Ronnie Jackson who gave
Trump a physical and mental exam a
cognitive test the the Montreal
cognitive assessment and he came out of
it saying Trump is just in great shape
he weighs 239 pounds and is 6 foot 3
inches tall obviously untrue every
picture of Donald Trump next to people
who we know are 6-3 or even 6:1 shows
that Trump is shorter we have pictures
of Donald Trump standing next to Barack
Obama for example who is known to be six
foot one and Trump looks maybe the same
height or maybe even sure
then Barack Obama so we know Trump's not
63 and 239 in terms of a weight just
happened to be the limit before obesity
for someone who is actually 6-3 so it
didn't make any sense it wasn't at all
believable with dr. Ronnie Jackson said
and then dr. Ronnie Jackson was
nominated to be Secretary of Veterans
Affairs a nomination that ultimately
imploded and ended up with dr. Ronnie
Jackson withdrawing from that so it all
stinks that gets us up to yesterday we
now have a comment from former vice
president Dick Cheney's cardiologist
Jonathan Reiner who says that he
believes the White House is hiding
something about Donald Trump's latest
physical exam tweeting yesterday quote
it's been four days since the president
underwent his annual physical exam and
still no data has been released what are
they hiding and indeed it has been four
days and instead of actual information
about Donald Trump's physical exam we
have this very strange vague memo the
new presidential doctor Shawn Connelly
put out a memo that's just ridiculous at
its face we have it up on the screen
Shawn Connelly wrote this afternoon at
Walter Reed National Military Medical
Center the president participated in a
second periodic physical examination
over the course of approximately four
hours I performed and supervised the
evaluation with a panel of 11 different
board-certified specialists he did not
undergo any procedures requiring
sedation or anesthesia the president is
very grateful as if this matters for the
outstanding care he received today and
he especially wants to thank all the
doctors nurses and listed in civilian
staff who participated of course none of
this says anything about trumps health
and then it ends with while the reports
and recommendations are being finalized
I'm happy to announce the President of
the United States is in very good health
and I anticipate he will remain so for
the duration of his presidency and
beyond how can any doctor predict in
such a casual way that a person who is
in
approaching their mid-70s and obese
doesn't exercise and has a terrible diet
how can you predict that they're going
to remain in good health for the rest of
their presidency and beyond it's a very
strange assertion for a medical
professional to make it's becoming more
Pat like the North Korean propaganda of
the dear leader doesn't defecate
engulfed all holes in one the first time
he played golf it's starting to be that
type of sort of hagiographic propaganda
yeah and for me I don't think the
president has to be an impeccable shape
although that is a bonus
I think if everything gets too bad and
you know someone can always replace them
or her right but the lying is what's
concerning and not just the fact the
Trump's lying but that he has the
network of physicians who are willing to
go along with it let me give you a
counter example just so you can see what
other medical reports look like four
presidents here's Barack Obama's report
from 2016 and you will notice that there
are very specific vital statistics about
his age height and weight his BMI his
pulse oximetry physical examination by
systems outlines eyes neck all sorts of
specifics and the second page of this
assessment actually has specific
laboratory results his lipid panel
including caress cholesterol numbers his
fasting blood glucose this is a serious
report about a president's weight what
medications are they on what vitamins
are there they taking this isn't crazy
stuff and we don't even know what
Trump's weight is being asserted to be
even though we know the last time we
were told it was 239 it was an obvious
lie I wonder is Donald Trump on
medications at this point we don't even
know the answer to that so the point is
doctors are now noticing this even from
the way that Donald Trump just speaks
incoherently at public events it should
convey to any reasonable person that
he's not in the best of health and from
what I recall Pat tell me if I'm wrong
we still haven't gotten an explanation
about the weird god bless the United
States of America incident have we
because
at one point asserted that maybe Dec
sure that dentures were related but then
we were told the president doesn't even
wear dentures what did they say it was
dry mouth something like that
when I get dry mouth I don't start
slurring my words like that I think it
was dentures for sure
well yeah again there's a denial that
the guy even wears dentures so I don't
know that we've gotten a clear answer
about that so medical professionals are
noticing and this is not about this is a
totally separate issue from Trump's
positions on issues and his ability to
negotiate deals or what I think of his
tax plan to some degree the public does
have a right to know the truth about the
president's health it's not crazy to
consider the individuals health in
making an evaluation about whether to
vote for them initially or to vote for
them for re-election and what it does
relate to is the pattern of lying and
deception and just putting out
information that most reasonable people
recognize as having holes in it or
potentially even of being downright
deceptively deliberately deceptive and
we're not getting those answers here and
we're just getting of strange comments
after strange comments from every single
medical professional who's allowed
around Donald Trump and this I can't I
don't even have time to get into this
today but the Montreal cognitive
assessment that Trump was given by dr.
Ronnie Jackson meant to be proof that
Donald Trump cognitively is fine we've
learned so much about why the specifics
of those results also don't really tell
us what we need to know about Trump will
we ever know the truth I don't know but
maybe someday I am taking questions
today your questions on the David Pakman
show Instagram page if you find David
Pakman show on Instagram and go to
today's stories feed you will see that
there is a place you can type in
questions for me and I'll be answering
them throughout the afternoon and
evening for the rest of the day and
while you're there follow me on
Instagram as well
at David Pakman quick break then bill
scher will join me I've not been playing
electability games with the 22
Democratic primary he believes that
playing electability games at this early
stage is already very very important
we'll hear from him next ok let's start
today with a correction yesterday I
mistakenly said that FDR's New Deal came
after World War two it came before World
War two I misspoke there and plenty of
people wrote in and said David you
should correct and that's what I'm doing
ok we have news on the Mexican border
wall of course we've been following this
ever since Donald Trump's campaign where
he said he would build a wall across the
entire us-mexico border and Mexico would
pay for it nobody who had any common
sense believed that even for a second
and then this transitioned into Donald
Trump shutting down the government
because Americans wouldn't pay for the
border wall of course it was Congress
who ultimately decided that they were
not going to give Donald Trump the money
he wanted to start that border wall we
subsequently learned from engineering
reports about this border wall that it's
going to be an impossibility to actually
do it during Donald Trump's presidency
even if it lasts six years because there
is simply no way that it's going to
happen from a logistical standpoint the
prototypes of the wall that were put
together were just that they were
prototypes they didn't account for
actually getting all of the materials
and workers to the places on the border
that would be required if we were indeed
to build a border wall across the entire
border so that's basically gone it's
merely a fantasy and so the question now
is are we going to have a shutdown at
the end of this week on February 15th if
there is no deal that includes some
money for some piece of Donald Trump's
wall which is really all that Donald
Trump could hope to get at this point at
least during this first term as
president Trump last night was giving a
propaganda rally in El Paso Texas he
simultaneously was sort of involved
distantly with negotiations happening
between Democrats and Republicans to see
if indeed a deal can be reached before
we get to potentially another government
shutdown there
is a tentative agreement we are being
told it's an agreement in principle but
of course we have to see how do people
actually vote and is this something that
Donald Trump would get behind and it
includes not a single penny for the
us-mexico border wall there is a billion
dollars remember the the full wall would
cost according to some engineering
reports upward of 50 billion dollars
there is a billion dollars potentially
earmarked in this new deal for what are
called bollards bollards are a
particular type of barrier that exists
in some spots along the us-mexico border
some call it border fencing and in
exchange for that Democrats have
successfully included in this
negotiation the reduction of 20% of
detention beds available to ice this
would be a really big deal and good for
the left because it would make it so
that ice has to be way more selective in
terms of who they detain it would make
the entire system have to work more
quickly because of the limited number of
detention beds that would be available
so that's a really good thing if it ends
up being part of the final deal and
Donald Trump seems to be totally
disconnected from reality as this is
going on as I mentioned he held a rally
in El Paso Texas last night he wrongly
claimed that El Paso is one of the most
dangerous cities in the United States
the reality is that it's been one of the
safest cities of its size in the United
States for a long time it was very safe
before they put in some border fencing
miles it remains safe after they put in
a little bit of border fencing and now
it is going to be up to Donald Trump is
Donald Trump going to choose to shut
down the border yet it down the
government yet again which will have
political consequences or is Donald
Trump going to accept this deal that
includes again this sort of billion
dollar token for some bollards on the
border and it's really important to
understand that ballers aren't the wall
bollards are what we've been seeing in
some spots for a very
very long time these have been put up
sporadically in different parts of the
border for years or is Donald Trump
going to accept it and call it the wall
and that is a very very real possibility
and it has the real possibility of
actually convincing his supporters that
he did it he's building the wall what is
amazing about this Pat is that the
original bipartisan Senate bill from
December had more than a billion dollars
for border fencing and Trump rejected it
outright
if Trump had done nothing and by that I
mean no shutdown no to Oval Office
speeches about how we have an
immigration crisis if he had done none
of that stuff he could have had way more
than a billion dollars simply by saying
yes back in December I think that he may
take this deal because another
government shutdown or declaring a
national emergency both of those things
would be really bad for him politically
and he also has backed off the idea of
building a concrete wall like remember
during the government shutdown he talked
about installing steel slats this is
kind of similar he made he may accept
the billion dollars tolled towards
Bullards and call it a victory yeah and
what's important also to remember is
that there was a deal on the table a
full year ago that was a much bigger
package and it could have put almost
twenty five billion dollars not just for
a wall but for a bunch of border
security in exchange for permanent
status for daca recipients or at least a
path to citizenship really the art of
the deal right supposedly the best
negotiator he's waded out multiple
better deals from the perspective of the
wall builders and now he might have to
claim victory over a billion bucks for
some additional bollards I mean just an
amazingly bad negotiator and supposedly
he was going to be the negotiator in
chief that's why we were supposed to
vote for him truly unbelievable when
Donald Trump selected Matthew Whitaker
to be his acting Attorney General after
Jeff Sessions was forced out we knew
that there were endless problems with
this we knew about Whitaker's previous
comments about how if he were in a
position to influence the Robert Moeller
Trump Russia investigation he has very
specific ideas for
how he would starve it of funds in order
to prevent it from happening effectively
we've talked about how Matthew Whitaker
is on the record previously as publicly
saying he believes that the entire Trump
Russia investigation by robert muller is
an overreach from a legal perspective
and so where we kind of came to what we
ended up in terms of our conclusions was
that Matthew Whitaker had no business
whatsoever being acting Attorney General
for even an hour never mind a few months
but ultimately he remained in that
position and continues to be in it today
until Attorney General bar is presumably
confirmed at some point relatively soon
so that gets us to Friday on Friday
Whitaker testified before the House
Judiciary Committee and it was such a
gong show of embarrassment for all that
is good and logical in the world and I'm
gonna play some clips for you here we're
going to start with congressman Jerry
Nadler who asked a really simple
question which was have you ever been
asked to approve any request or action
to be taken by the special counsel and
his answer was congressman your time is
up and you will actually hear the room
audibly gasp and groan at this answer
from Matthew Whitaker take a look at
this in your capacity as acting Attorney
General have you ever been asked to
approve any request or action to be
taken by the special counsel mr.
Chairman I see that your five minutes is
up and so we I am maybe I'm here
voluntarily we have agreed to five
minute rounds committee that's a fine
place T in the five minute rule you
can't use the fact that your testimony
is voluntary as a reason not to answer
and if anything that's a reason to
subpoena this guy right away and get
answers to these questions and then in
comes congressman David Cicilline from
Rhode Island and he starts getting into
it with Whitaker and it goes just as
poorly take a look you were briefed by
the special counsel you've acknowledged
that did you share that information with
any members of your staff the
information you learned in that briefing
from the special counsel or his team
congressman as i previously tested
five there was one other individual in
that briefing with and who is that
individual it is the US Attorney from
the Eastern District of California who
I've brought on what is the name of the
individual mr. Whittaker his name is
Greg Scott so that's the did you
communicate any information you learned
in those briefing to other members of
your staff I don't believe so no so that
you understand those slow answers those
pauses from Whittaker are because at the
beginning of his five minutes
congressman Cicilline said I have
limited time I don't need you to thank
me for my questions I don't need you to
say the questions or good just answer
the questions and then Whittaker adopted
this strategy of just pausing for a few
seconds before each answer and it kept
going and it was just as bad do you know
whether any information that you learned
in those briefings were communicated to
anyone at the White House as I mentioned
previously congressman we have kept a
very close mr. Whittaker it's a yes or a
No do you know whether it was commuted
to anybody at the White House as I see
here today I don't I don't I don't know
whether it was communicated you know any
restrictions or limitations or
instructions to your staff not to share
this information with anyone at the
White House or the president's legal
team yes together with the general
standard that investigative information
and materials are need-to-know in law
enforcement Thank You mr. Whittaker Tim
you've got to hand it to him I mean he's
doing a great job of eating up as much
of those five minutes as possible
without really saying anything let's
continue to the third clip did the
president lash out at you after Michael
Cohen's guilty plea for lying to
Congress about a Trump organization
project to build a tower in Moscow the
president specifically tweeted that he
had not laughed I did I'm asking you mr.
Whittaker did the president lash out at
you not asking what he tweeted I don't
have a lot of confidence in the veracity
of his tweets I'm asking you under oath
congressman that is based on an
unsubstantiated sir answer the question
yes or no did the president lash out to
you about mr. Cohen's guilty plea no he
did not
and did anyone from the White House or
anyone on the president's behalf
shouting you know so then we get into a
really good logic pretzel on January
22nd congressman Nadler sent Whittaker a
letter with questions that Democrats
might ask him during exactly these
hearings that were watching about his
conversations with Donald Trump and in
the letter but Nadler tells Whittaker
consult with the White House ahead of
time about whether Donald Trump would
invoke executive privilege over those
questions
allowing Whittaker not to answer without
simply refusing to answer this is really
key Cicilline asks Whittaker whether he
showed the questions to the White House
and Whittaker says that he didn't so
thus if Whittaker hasn't shown the
questions to the White House there'd be
no way to assert privilege and it gets
really confusing and then Whittaker just
won't answer whether or not he's
actually spoken to Donald Trump about
the molar or any other investigation
into him which of course he shouldn't be
doing did you walk share the questions
that mr. Nadler forwarded to you prior
to this hearing with anyone at the White
House or the president's legal counsel
um congressman I did not so when you
claimed earlier that you are going to
invoke a privilege you bugging a
privilege about questions the president
hasn't even seen congressman to be clear
I'm not invoking any privilege
well you said earlier that you in your
written testimony that you would not
answer questions about your
conversations with the President did you
not yes I do you are not sitting here
today saying the president has
instructed you not to answer a question
correct I am NOT sitting here today
saying that the president hasn't so then
you're prepared to answer all these
questions congressman I think I was
pretty explicit in my opening statement
so have you spoken to the president mr.
Whitaker about the Muller investigation
congressman as I have previously
testified I had did not talk talk to the
president about the more of us have you
ever spoken to the President or members
or parts of his legal team about
information that you've learned in your
capacity as acting attorney general
related to the mother investigation or
any other criminal investigation
involving the president congressman
while I have
specifically been saying that I'm not
going to comment about my conversations
with the President or his senior staff I
have also been very clear that the
president has not instructed me to do
anything I said that wasn't my question
my question is have you had
conversations about what you learned
that's a yes or no
congressman I have I spend all day every
day mr. Whitacre mic questions very
specific have you spoken to the
president or his legal team about what
you've learned in the Muller
investigation or were the related
criminal investigations that may involve
the president yes or no congressman as I
specifically answered earlier two of the
what you're clearly not gonna answer the
question so I'm gonna move on yeah so we
don't get any further with that and then
the cherry on top pad is that after the
hearing Whitaker was spotted at Trump
International Hotel in Washington DC
when you watched this does this guy
strike you as honest and forthcoming and
transparent well I'm glad he's just the
acting Attorney General and I think
compared to this guy William Bar is
going to do a lot better it's not easy
to obstruct justice I mean the president
has struggled with that continually over
the past couple of years and Whitaker
didn't do too well either no certainly
not and we will see ultimately what the
day is where Attorney General future
Attorney General bar takes over the
Trump White House has a real big problem
with leaks and leakers and this includes
leaks about the content of meetings that
were not for public consumption this
includes leaks about Trump flipping out
on people in the Oval Office this
includes leaks about other people
fighting at the Oval Office including
one story about I believe it was john
bolton and former chief of staff John
Kelly leaks about a lot of the nonsense
that's going on and recently it's been
about Trump's daily schedules which have
shown that Trump on a lot of days is
just doing nothing he has this so-called
executive time for all or even most of a
lot of days and hilariously chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney said just a few days
ago that they expect to identify the
staffer who is leaking Trump schedules
within the next week and literally hours
later there were new Trump schedules
that were leaked showing that it's just
executive time he's doing nothing other
than sometimes having lunch
with Mike Pence and there's sort of two
stories here one is just the hilarity of
how they can't seem to identify who is
leaking the stuff and it can't be that
big of a circle of people that would
even have the ability to leak this stuff
it's been months and they can't seem to
figure out who it is that's hilarious
and it just goes to the general
incompetence that we've seen out of the
White House
then there's the material significance
of Trump not working what we're learning
from looking at the schedules themselves
is that Trump is spending fifty to sixty
percent of his time overall and
sometimes nearly entire week's
unscheduled with nothing going on other
than I guess tweeting and watching TV so
the leaks keep happening
Trump's responses to all of this are the
height of idiocy going totally overboard
in his defenses claiming that executive
time is when he's getting a lot of stuff
done after a recent series of scheduled
leaks Donald Trump took to Twitter and
said that quote the media was able to
get my work schedule something very easy
to do but it should have been reported
as a positive not a negative when the
term executive time is used I am
generally working not relaxing in fact I
probably work more hours than almost any
past president and as usual the
hyperbole is very very easily defeated
we know that President Obama would read
in the mornings he would read in the
evenings he would have briefings and
meetings he would often be up until 1:00
or 2:00 in the morning working not
tweeting Bill Clinton would make phone
calls in the middle of the night George
W Bush more of a morning guy would often
be in the Oval Office by 6:45 in the
morning
the only late-night work that we know of
Trump doing is wasn't it when he called
Pat Michael Flynn at like 3:00 a.m. and
said is a strong dollar good or bad
right Michael Flynn is National Security
Advisor who presumably knows nothing
about whether a good of whether a strong
dollar is good or bad wrong guy to ask
yeah and and every time this comes up we
get back to do we want him working right
like when Trump does work it's either
destructive for the US internationally
to enrich himself personally so I hope
that the leaks continue endlessly until
everybody gets fired from the White
House and when we go back to trump's
going to hire the best people I think
the meme was are you doing that if you
have someone this close to you leaking
such personal information and it goes on
for months and you can't find them now
it's not going to affect his base as we
just heard right as we just heard from
Bobby Azarian this is certainly not
going to impact his bait base and
executive time is a vague enough term
that maybe some in his base will
actually believe the defense that he is
really doing work during that time but
the most important question for me is
maybe in some sense it's good that
Donald Trump isn't working much because
if the damage he does when he actually
does political things let's talk about
the green New Deal legislation that is
now out co-sponsored by congresswoman
Alexandria Casio Cortez in the house and
by Senator Ed Markey in the Senate the
idea of a green new deal is we want to
deal with two major issues climate
change and economic inequality New Deal
refers to Franklin Delano Roosevelt in
the post-world War two ERA stimulus
infrastructure job creation and the idea
of a green new deal is to do another New
Deal but one that takes into account
everything we know about climate change
in the environment so AOC and Markey put
out a 14-page resolution the right goes
bonkers saying there's no details this
is pie in the sky it can never be done
it's impractical we've got no way to pay
for it it doesn't make any sense
even Nancy Pelosi is being careful about
the green New Deal saying it's an
enthusiastic idea and that's good but
she's also kind of laughing it off by
calling it the green dream so right away
the main thing is is this a step-by-step
list of policies with a guide as to how
to implement them and how to pay for
them the answer is no is it just a list
of things which would be nice with no
other relevance no is this 14 page
proposal
meant to become the law not really but
that doesn't mean that it can't be
impactful so what I'm going to tell you
first is what the green New Deal wants
to do now and then I'll tell you where I
think Democrats may be going wrong with
this but that doesn't mean that it's a
bad proposal okay but this green New
Deal is a list of goals and some of them
are vague some of them are unrealistic
in terms of their timing but it's a
really important list of what should be
priorities for any serious progressive
candidates at this point everybody
should read it before commenting it's
only 14 pages and the way they do these
resolutions the margins are gigantic
like you would never be allowed to turn
this in as a school paper it's only like
half the width of the page because it's
so narrow so there's very little text on
the page the first two pages just kind
of frame the situation so it's very
little actual text every single one of
you should look at it
the proposal gives a ten year time
horizon to do the following number one
get to Net Zero greenhouse gas emissions
with 100 percent of power demand through
clean renewable zero emission energy
sources okay yeah it's not realistic
doing it in ten years while at the same
time upgrading all existing buildings in
the United States to the most modern
standard it's extraordinary
excuse me extraordinarily unlikely you'd
be able to do that in ten years but this
is actually exactly what the goal should
be creating millions of jobs is a goal
okay that's great we should say more
about how investing in infrastructure
but sustainably fine securing clean air
water climate resiliency healthy food
access to nature and a sustainable
environment fantastic it's short on the
details but we'll get to that promoting
justice and equity by stopping and
preventing oppressions of all kinds I
like it but you've got to be more
specific about exactly what you're
talking about and hopefully at some
point we will see that there's a lot of
even more vague ideas like for example
quote building a more sustainable food
system that ensures universal access to
healthy food that sounds good but we
got to talk about the specifics of what
we mean by that
investing in high-speed rail and public
transit absolutely but we're gonna have
to flesh out how there are some more
specific items like cleaning up
hazardous waste and abandoned sites that
are toxic at this point we should do it
of course the most important thing about
this document though for me is the
timing because it's a totally fair
criticism that this doesn't lay out
exactly how you do these things although
that's not uncommon in these initial
proposals it's a fair criticism that it
doesn't outline how to pay for it that's
also common it's very common that when
you get a proposal in the House or
Senate the proposal says what you want
to do you separately outline how it
would be paid for in an appropriations
bill it's a fair critique but that's
commonly how these things work the most
important thing about this document is
that with the Democratic primary ramping
up no 20:20 democrat has straight-up
backed away from it you do have some
Democrats paint playing a little coy
with it like Elizabeth Warren said she's
into it but when she was asked what
specifically do you support in it she
didn't say cory booker i forget exactly
what he said about it but it was again
this kind of more timid support of it
but if you if at this point you're
running in 2020 is a democrat and you
say i am against the bill that's a real
problem and that's a good thing and
that's one of the most important things
that this bill that this proposal
actually does now we do need to figure
out a path to doing it and that's a
really important thing and what we're
already running into is that you have a
number of people on the left making
strategic mistakes like for example i
saw an adviser to alexandria Acacio
cortez on the tucker carlson show I
apologize that I forget his name I
believe he's a Cornell University law
professor and a lot of the defenses that
he issued were arguing that Tucker had
merely misunderstood the proposal and
what AOC tweeted and said about it and
some of the denials were really not
particularly believable I think that
that's a mistake I think the idea that
that would much better serve the left
would be to be completely on the same
page that listen it doesn't say how we
pay for it
that's normal separately we're going to
put out a proposal for how to pay for it
that's what Bernie did with Medicare for
all and then with how to pay for it when
they say a lot of these things are too
ambitious you respond and you say these
are the goals let's see how much of it
we can actually get done it's a really
bad idea in my estimation to sort of
back away and play semantics games as
I've seen some people do that's why the
right ends up winning they say we're
gonna prioritize ending abortion as we
know it and tax cuts for everyone and
then they pass some restrictions on
abortion and then they cut taxes for the
rich and corporations but then they can
claim victory and they are putting
points up on the board and they end up
getting themselves reelected the left
should not fall into the game of saying
okay fine maybe we're not going to do it
in ten years maybe we would shoot for
fifty percent net zero fifty percent of
the way towards net zero in 15 years or
something like that that's a mistake
that is a mistake we should actually be
taking a page from the right here in
terms of how to handle the criticisms of
this proposal I want to hear from you
i'm on instagram at david pakman the
show is on instagram at david pakman
show we're now learning the full scope
of the absurdity of this rally we've
been discussing Donald Trump's El Paso
Texas build the wall rally on Monday
night I've already told you some
examples of why this is just so wacky
and why riddled and problematic number
one is that Donald Trump had previously
said that El Paso is a very dangerous
City a border city when the truth of
course is that El Paso is one of the
safest cities of its size in the United
States it was safe before a little bit
of border fencing was put up and it
remained safe after that bit of border
fencing was put up but Donald Trump
choosing to say it's an incredibly
dangerous place and it proves why we
need the wall we already talked today
about this assault on a BBC cameraman
just moments after Donald Trump again
slammed the media during the speech we
also have discuss
the kind of hilarity maybe contrast is a
better way to say it of Donald Trump
talking about yes the wall is definitely
getting built on Monday night at this
rally as Republicans were in the process
of agreeing with Democrats in principle
to a deal that has no substantive law
border wall funding but a sort of
billion dollar handout for some bollards
on a measly 55 miles of the border so
now we get to just a kind of more
cartoonish hilarious Trump lie it's kind
of like the sequel to the entire
inauguration crowd Fiasco from Donald
Trump's 2017 inauguration during the
rally in El Paso Texas
two nights ago Donald Trump bizarrely
claimed that exceptions had been made by
the El Paso Fire Department to allow
even more people into the building than
the number that would normally be
allowed presumably by the fire code this
is so specific and so pointless and so
untrue but for some weird reason Trump
chose to concoct this lie let's take a
look at that moment from the speech
there's never been if you would say as
an example that tonight 69 thousand
people signed up to be here now the
arena holds eight thousand and thank you
Fire Department they got in about ten
thank you Fire Department
so anyway that's just not true the El
Paso Fire Department has now commented
on this because if there's an allegation
made that the fire department allowed 25
percent more people than should safely
be allowed into the building that's
that's a real problem right and the El
Paso Fire Department has said no we
didn't do anything to allow more people
into the arena than it's meant to hold
or more people than the facility is
permitted to allow but here's where it
gets even wackier the El Paso Fire
Department was there and they said the
capacity of the arena is 6500 not 8,000
as Donald Trump claimed the actual
attendance of the event was also 6500
not 10,000 as Donald Trump said why does
Donald Trump keep lying about crowd
sizes and a big part of this entire
thing is this fixation on crowd size
seems to be that Trump wanted his thing
to be bigger than beta O'Rourke's he
doesn't like the idea of bid O'Rourke
having a bigger thing than Trump has so
when it became clear that Vado
O'Rourke's rally to even call it that as
maybe not even the right term but the
rally in which beta or participated had
between 10 and 15 thousand people Trump
all of a sudden felt like the size of
his thing was being put to shame with
only 6,500 so he just makes up that
8,000 is the number of people that would
normally be allowed in 10,000 is what we
had but who cares right that's the this
is the distraction I want to talk about
Donald Trump's obvious and brazen lies
but at the same time a bigger crowd
doesn't prove who has better ideas or
the right ideas or the smarter followers
this is a debate that only a very petty
man who just lies is even interested in
having and I think that that's the most
disturbing thing of all let me know what
you think is behind Donald Trump lying
about the size of his thing I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show